yes I am joined in the studio by our
very special guest Janna Thomas welcome
thank you uh Jenna you're the Scholastic
coordinator
um at the Saint Louis chess club please
tell us more about this very special
program okay well our Scholastics
program is a great program that allows
us to reach out to students in many
schools we're in I'm sure over a hundred
schools at this time adding schools
every year
and definitely servicing more than our
what we thought was 80 000 students
we're topping that now so since the
beginning of the program these are the
numbers yes
and what is your favorite aspect of the
of the program how does it affect the
students tell us well my favorite part
of teaching chess is relating it to life
think it's an important game to learn
because it can be used as a tool for
achieving goals
so students
will first have to be aware and that
takes Focus which we develop but they
have to be aware of their position or
situation on the board and in life and
then they have to accept that reality
and start their trial and error of like
building opportunities and removing
obstacles on their journey to their goal
and so that is exactly what they're
doing on the chessboard and I've seen
them absorb that and then transfer that
from the board to life and that just
that is very rewarding for me
well actually it was a part of this
program program but in the Soviet Union
so I wanted to ask you at what age kids
start
as soon as they can most of our youngest
students are around four to five yeah
we have
taught some preschoolers most of our
classrooms are going to be
kindergartening up
okay and I've heard there are also
summer camps where uh well which lasts I
think for one or two weeks where
children can learn for several hours a
day absolutely we have so many camps
this summer uh summer is extremely
popular last year was our best year and
we're looking to service at least 50
percent more students this summer we
have space in all of our camps still
available and thanks to our partners
Ascension Health we're able to have the
summer camps in the Jennings and
Ferguson Florissant areas so we have
lots of camps to offer and if anybody's
still interested they should go to our
website and feel free to contact us
about registration
well tell us a little bit more about
this because I would imagine that it's
like Rolling Stones concert you know the
moment you have the announcement so
every spot is taken do you have a few
spots left absolutely we have plenty of
Splats left because we are trying to
have camps as big as 50 to 60 students
right so we have various levels for
students to learn it it's not just
Advanced we have intermediate and
beginner students so all students are
welcome so they should simply go online
and fill in the application yes yes and
if they have any questions make sure to
email or call us because we'll get them
straightened out yes so it's important
of course to have all the information on
Saint Louis chess club.com
dot org I think dot org yes and uh this
is a wonderful initiative you know it
brings back a lot of memories from my
childhood so thank you so much Jenna and
well please join uh this program and the
summer camps yes definitely come on out
join us thank you uh Jenna for all the
work you do